STARTING LATE HERE ARE CAUCUS
ROOM LOW OVER TIME SO I THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
JUST A COUPLE ANNOUNCEMENTS FOR
START WE HAVE SEPT COUPLE ITEMS
BEFORE US TODAY.
WE'RE HERE TO WITNESSES PER SIDE
WITH A TIME LIMIT OF THREE
MINUTES EACH.
WHO HAVE ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
STATING ONLY THEIR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION FOR THE RECORD?
WITH THEIR POSITION.
AFTER THOSE OF YOUR POSITION
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE -- OR
THOSE WHO HAVE NO POSITION --
PLEASE GIVE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION VERY BRIEFLY
EXPLAIN YOUR POSITION ITSELF
[inaudible]
BUT THAT.
FIRST ITEM UP.
WHO WAS IT WE DO IN FILE ORDER
SO -- TO
CUNNINGHAM
.
YES.
IT'S R. SORRY ABOUT THAT I THIS
IS NOT MY NORMAL ROOM ARE NORMAL
ROOMS THAT HAVE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
HERE TO PRESENT AB SIX FIFTY
THREE SO IN THE MIDDLE OF SANTA
BARBARA COUNTIES WHERE THE THE
RURAL PART OF IT.
IS A TOWN CALLED LOMPOC IT'S FUN
POKED NOT LOMPOC EVEN THOUGH IT
LOOKS LIKE LOMPOC.
SO IN LONG POKE --
YOU'VE GOT AT AN INTERESTING
SITUATION YOU'VE GOT A TOWN THAT.
KIND OF IN BETWEEN AN AIRFORCE
SPACE BEEN A BURGER FOR SPACE
AND A FEDERAL PRISON LONG POKE
[inaudible]
FEDERAL PENITENTIARY I ITS
GEOGRAPHICALLY PRETTY ISOLATED
IT'S FIFTY TWO MILES FROM THE
HOSPITAL AND A AND SANTA BARBARA
IT'S FORTY MILES FROM HOSPITALS
AND MARIA.
SO IT'S A CRITICALLY UNDERSERVED
REGION AND WHAT WE'RE SIMPLY
TRYING TO DO WITH THIS BILL IS
ALLOW COTTAGE HOSPITAL NONPROFIT
TO ENTER.
INTO A JPA WITH THE LOMPOC
VALLEY HEALTHCARE DISTRICT ARE
TO TRY TO BRING MORE PRIMARY
CARE PHYSICIANS THE AREA.
I DON'T BELIEVE THERE'S ANY SUCH
A COSTS WITH MEETS CATS GOT TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
YEAH.
I CAN [inaudible]
BANKING AND NICE TRY.
WE TAKE IT SECOND THAT FOR YOU
THAT CATHARINE AUSTIN'S
RESIGNING A LUMP WHO.
MEDICAL CENTER --
WHICH IS A DISTRICT HOSPITAL AND
THEREFORE WE NEED THE JP EIGHT
TO ENTER INTO A JOINT VENTURE
NOR TO MAINTAIN AND IMPROVE
SERVICES.
I'M IN THE LONG HOGAN SANTA
BARBARA AREA SO WITHOUT COTTAGE
HOSPITAL --
AS THAT VENTURE PARTNER HOW WE
ASK I THINK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DID A FANTASTIC JOB EXPLAINING
THE PURPOSES OF HOUSE FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
A WITNESSES OTHER WITNESSES AND
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
CNN BRING BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
I JUST SAY IT SOUNDS A LOT LIKE
MY DISTRICT.
THIS IS WHERE YOU DON'T HAVE A
LOT OF ACCESS AND AND AND LOTS
OF DISTANCES IN BETWEEN SO.
OTHER THE THE BILL DOES HAVE A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION WHEN WE
DO HAVE A QUORUM SO OVERWEIGHT
AT THAT AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH
REPRESENTATION WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSER.
WITH I DO I DO THAT EVERY
ASTRONAUT OKAY.
THINKS IT OF SENATOR PAN
[inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
HAVE YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I S. C. ARE ONE FORTY
THREE ENCOURAGES THE MOTION
PICTURE INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION OF
AMERICA TO GIVE IT OUR RATING TO
ANY NEW FILM THAT FEATURES
TOBACCO PRODUCTS.
OR TOBACCO USE WITH ONLY LIMITED
EXCEPTIONS SMOKING PROCESS IS A
LEADING CAUSE OF PREVENTABLE
DEATH BOTH IN THE UNITED STATES
AND WORLDWIDE CAUSES MORE THAN
FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
DEATHS IN THE UNITED STATES EACH
YEAR.
IN TWENTY TWELVE THE US SURGEON
GENERAL DETERMINE THAT THERE IS
A CAUSAL RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
YOUTH VIEWING OF SMOKING IN
MOVIES AND INITIATION SMOKING.
TWENTY FOURTEEN THE CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL PREVENTION
REPORT EXPOSURE TO DEPICTIONS OF
SMOKING IN MOVIES WILL COST
ABOUT SIX POINT FOUR MILLION.
CHILDREN ALIVE TODAY TO BECOME
SMOKERS.
THE PEDIATRICIAN I KNOW THAT THE
ABSOLUTE BEST WAY TO PREVENT
THAT'S RELATED TO SMOKING IS TO
PREVENT YOUTH FROM EVER BECOMING
ADDICTED TO THESE DEADLY
PRODUCTS IN THE FIRST PLACE.
A PROUD OF SUPPORT CALIFORNIA'S
LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS TO RAISE THE
MINIMUM WAGE TO PURCHASE TO BACK
ON REGULATE E. CIGARETTES HE'S
MEASURES GO A LONG WAY TO
ENSURING THAT OUR FUTURE
GENERATIONS WILL NOT FACE THE
SAME BURNED AT THE BACK OF
RELATED DISEASES.
HOWEVER OUR RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
THERE'S EVEN MORE TO BE DONE TO
KEEP KIDS FROM SMOKING DRAW IF
SOMEONE DOESN'T INITIATE SMOKING
BY TIME THEY'RE IN THEIR MID
TWENTIES ARE UNLIKELY TO DO SO.
NEARLY HALF A CENTURY AGO THE U.
S. BAR TOBACCO ADVERTISING ON
TELEVISION RADIO.
HOWEVER CHILDREN CONTINUE TO BE
EXPOSED TO TOBACCO USE IN MOVIES
WITH PGP G. THIRTEEN RATING
RATINGS.
OUTSIDE OF THE LEGISLATURE TO
LEAD THE WAY BY URGING THOSE
RESPONSIBLE FOR RATING MOVIES TO
TAKE ACTIONS.
IF YOU'RE YOUTH WILL STAR START
SMOKING IF ALL MOVIES THAT THE
TO PICK.
TOBACCO USE ARE GIVEN AN R.
RATING.
I APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT MADE --
URGENT AYE VOTE ON THIS YEAR --
ONE FORTY THREE NOW PLEASED TO
HAVE AS WITNESSES A SUPPORT
DAVID BESET WITH GRIEF
CALIFORNIA AND TIM GIVES WITH
THE AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY
CANCER ACTION NETWORK.
ALSO HAVE WITH ME JONATHAN
POLANSKI CONSULTANT TO THE US
CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL
PREVENTION AND THE UC SAN
FRANCISCO CENTER FOR TOBACCO
CONTROL.
RESEARCH AND EDUCATION FOR ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DAVE MODEST
THAT -- I'M
WITH BRIEF CALIFORNIA SACRAMENTO
REGION --
OUR ORGANIZATION --
AS A PUBLIC HEALTH ORGANIZATION
WE'VE BEEN.
MEADOW TO IMPROVE LONG HEALTH
SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTEEN SO OVER
A HUNDRED YEARS AYE AND AS PART
OF OUR WORK FOR THE LAST TWENTY
FIVE YEARS WE'VE WE'VE BEEN --
CATEGORIZING --
SMOKING AND TOBACCO SCENES IN
MAJOR MOTION MOTION PICTURES --
AND THAT DATA IS USED BY PUBLIC
HEALTH ORGANIZATIONS AROUND THE
WORLD -- SO
THIS ISSUE HAS BEEN STUDIED AT
LENGTH --
ANY GREAT IN GREAT DETAIL AND
THERE'S CONSENSUS IN THE MEDICAL
AND PUBLIC HEALTH COMMUNITIES --
ON THIS ISSUE SO WHAT ARE THE
FACTS.
I GUESS FIRST OF ALL THAT
SMOKING SCENES AND YOU THE RATED
MOVIES ACTUALLY BECAUSE CHILDREN
AND TEENAGERS TO STARTS TO START
SMOKING.
THIS WAS THE FINDING OF THE
SURGEON GENERAL IN TWENTY TWELVE
SECONDLY THAT 37% OF ALL NEW
YOUNG SMOKERS START SMOKING
BECAUSE OF THE SMOKING SCENES IN
MOVIES.
THIRDS EVEN TODAY 50% OF ALL P.
G. THIRTEEN OF MOVIES CONTAINS
SCENES OF SMOKING AND TOBACCO
AND LASTLY AS THE SENATOR SAID.
THE US CENTER FOR DISEASE
CONTROL ESTIMATES THAT SIX POINT
FOUR MILLION CHILDREN WILL START
START SMOKING AS RESULT OF THESE
SMOKING SCENES TWO MILLION OF
THOSE WILL DIE PREMATURELY.
FROM TOBACCO RELATED LUNG CANCER
STROKE HEART DISEASE ARM THE
POLICY RECOMMENDATION UNLESS YOU
ARE ONE FORTY THREE DOES COME
FROM THE US CENTER FOR TO FOR
DISEASE CONTROL AND AS I SAID
THERE'S A CONSENSUS AMONG THE
PUP PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND MEDICAL COMMUNITIES ON THIS.
AND AS YOU KNOW THE MOTION
PICTURE ASSOCIATION GIVES IN OUR
RATING TO MOVIES THAT HAVE BAD
LANGUAGE.
ABOUT WE CURRENTLY DO NOT --
GIVE THE SAME RATING TO A
PRACTICE TOBACCO USE THAT WE
KNOW IS BECAUSE THE YOUNG PEOPLE
TO BECOME ADDICTED TO HAVE MAJOR
HEALTH PROBLEMS DURING THEIR
LIVES AND MANY OF THEM.
TO DIE PREMATURELY THIS JUST
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
S. C. ARE ONE FORTY THREE IS NOT
A MANDATE IT'S NOT A STATUTE IT
IS A REQUEST A RECOMMENDATION
THAT THE MOTION PICTURE INDUSTRY
BRING ITS RATING SYSTEM UP TO
DATE.
WITH THE CURRENT MEDICAL AND
SCIENTIFIC FACTS ON THE ISSUE
AND WITH THE CONSENSUS OF THE
MEDICAL AND PUBLIC HEALTH
COMMUNITIES.
THE MOTION PICTURE ASSOCIATION
CAN SAVE ONE MILLION KIDS FROM
DISEASEAND DEATH IF THEY
IMPLEMENT THIS RECOMMENDATION WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
RIGHT GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN FIRST HIM GIVES THE
AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY CANCER
ACTION NETWORK IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
VOTERS PASSED PROPOSITION FIFTY
SIX WHICH INCREASE THE TOBACCO
TAX BY TWO DOLLARS PER PACK WILL
PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES TO
EDUCATE CHILDREN ABOUT THE
DANGERS OF SMOKING.
HOWEVER IMAGES OF FAMOUS ACTORS
SMOKING IN FILMS REPRESENT A
DANGER AND COULD POTENTIALLY
UNDER MOUNTING THE IMPORTANT
WORK PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX
FUNDED PROGRAMS ARE THAT THEY
YOU KNOW THAT THEIR ACHIEVING IT.
AND OUR SCHOOLS --
AS PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED THE U.
S. SURGEON GENERAL'S REPORT
CONCLUDED THAT EXPOSURE TO
SMOKING IN MOVIES BECAUSE YOUNG
PEOPLE TO START SMOKING SMOKING
IN MOVIES HAS THE SAME AFFECT US
MORE TRADITIONAL TOBACCO.
MARKETING AND ADVERTISING BY THE
TOBACCO INDUSTRY.
AND THE REPORT WAS ON TO SUGGEST
THAT EFFORTS TO DECREASE
DEPICTIONS OF SMOKING IN MOVIES
IS.
HOT IS WARRANTED --
WERE PROUD CALIFORNIANS WHO
EMBRACE OUR STATE'S HISTORY OF
BEING THE LEADER IN GLOBAL FILM
PRODUCTION HOWEVER DUE TO THE
OUTSIZED INFLUENCE.
OUR UNDERSTATES YOUTH IT IS
OFTEN THE CALIFORNIA TAXPAYER
WHO FOOTS THE BILL FOR IMAGES OF
SMOKING --
IN FILMS AS TOBACCO RELATED
ILLNESS COSTS US THREE POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN DIRECT A
HEALTHCARE EXPENSES --
THROUGH MEDICAL.
SO FOR THESE REASONS WE ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE FOR THIS CRITICAL
RESOLUTION THAT COULD HELP TECH
COMPANIES IF.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
BEFORE YOU ASK BROTHERS IN
SUPPORT AMEND SECTION WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WE HAVE A
QUORUM IT LOOKS LIKE
[inaudible]
WOOD HERE.
MAYES HERE AGAR CURRY
[inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BONTA BURKE [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
FLORA [inaudible]
LIMON [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN.
RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO.
THURMOND HERE WALDRON HERE.
QUORUM AND SO OTHERS IN SUPPORT
JUST YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION
PLEASE GOOD AFTERNOON AND THE
GREATEST AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON BRED IN MARCH
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
Q..
WHEN SPENCER WITH THE COW FRANK
CATNIP FAMILY PHYSICIANS IN
SUPPORT?
LYDIA BORN AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA DIVISION
IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NO ONE OF BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
YOUR COMMENTS FROM COMMAND
[inaudible]
SURE.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON --
YOU KNOW.
IN IN GENERAL BY 1100% SUPPORT
THE IDEA THAT YOUNG PEOPLE
SHOULD NOT BE SMOKING AND FACT
ACTUALLY.
BELIEVE THAT WE COULD BE DOING.
UP.
MORE.
WHEN IT COMES TO TO YOUTH THEN
AND SMOKING HOWEVER?
I AM A FORMER PRODUCER FORMER
DIRECTOR.
AND I FIND IT A LITTLE
PROBLEMATIC THAT WE ARE GONNA
TAKE.
MAKE ARTISTIC DECISIONS ON A
WHAT COULD BE REAL LIFE
EXPERIENCES.
WHEN IT COMES TO FILM WHEN IT
COMES TO DEPICTING THE LIVES OF
YOUNG PEOPLE OF THE REALITIES
THAT THEY FACE EVERY SINGLE DAY?
I DON'T THINK THAT IT'S THE THE
JOB OF THIS LEGISLATURE TO
FIGURE OUT OR TRY TO TRY TO MAKE
CREATIVE DECISIONS ON FILMS FOR
THE MOVIE INDUSTRY.
BASED ON SMOKING I THINK THERE
ARE OTHER ALTERNATIVES THAT CAN
BE DONE LIKE THAT MAY BE A
WARNING.
AT THE END OF THE FILM MUCH LIKE
THERE ARE WARNINGS WHEN AYE
ANIMALS OR USE A NO ANIMALS ARE
HARMED THAT THE FILM DOES
ENCOURAGE SMOKING WHICH I
BELIEVE AND BUT I JUST DON'T
BELIEVE THAT.
WE SHOULD BE IN A POSITION OF
TELLING THE DIRECTOR PRODUCER
WHAT TO DO WITH ARTISTIC
EXPRESSION --
WHEN IT ACTUALLY IS OF A VERY --
DAILY LIFE EXPERIENCE OF A YOUNG
PERSON AND I'M ALSO CONCERNED OF
WHAT IT WOULD MEAN ECONOMICALLY.
IF WE WERE TO NOW CHANGE THE
RATING OF A FILM. TO WHEN OUR
RATING IN WHICH YOUNG PEOPLE
WILL NOT HAVE ACCESS --
TO AND THE IMPACT THAT THAT
WOULD HAVE IN MY DISTRICT HAVE A
LOT OF FOLKS THAT WORK IN THE
MOVIE INDUSTRY IN THE CITY
INDUSTRY MY DISTRICT --
AND THE IMPACT THAT THAT HOUSE
ON THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO I
I COMMAND FOR THE I COMMEND YOU
AREDOCTOR PATH FOR WANTING TO
MOVE SOMETHING FORWARD.
BUT I WILL BE ABSTAINING OF FROM
THOSE VOTE AND I HOPE TO WORK
WITH YOU IN THE FUTURE ON HOW WE
CAN TWEAK SOME OF THIS AND HOW
WE CAN HELP YOUNG PEOPLE IN THE
LONG RUN.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
[inaudible]
SURE.
I AM.
I JUST HAD A COMMENT BECAUSE MY
SON YOU KNOW MS VIDEO GAMES
EVERYTHING IN THE WAY THEY DO
THEIR RATINGS AND I'M NOT SURE
THIS OUR MEMBER YOU KNOW.
YOU JUST SEE YOU KNOW PT
THIRTEEN OR DOESN'T DO THEY LIST
ON THEIR WIRED SPEED YOU DON'T
JUST SAY VIOLENCE ERIC'S YOU
KNOW LANGUAGE.
YES I KNOW IN THE VIDEO GAMES
FAILSAFE T. FOR TEEN IN THE LIST
YOU KNOW LANGUAGE OR VIOLENCE OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
YEAH I'M JUST THINKING.
WHAT BELIEFS OF BELIEVE SO
STATEMENT?
AT LEAST THE BROAD.
CAT YES SEXUAL KONTOR BRAILLE
BROAD CATEGORIES OF AND AND AND
I WOULD MAKE NOTE I APPRECIATE
THAT YOU BRING THIS OFFICE IS
THAT -- THE
RATING SYSTEM IS NOT.
A THAT CENSORSHIP SYSTEM IT'S
ACTUALLY TO INFORM PARENTS RIGHT
OF WHAT --
WHAT --
THERE'D THEIR CHILDREN MIGHT BE
EXPOSED TO RIGHT AND IT'S THE
PARENTS TO JUDGE --
WHAT THEY THINK IT'S ACCEPTABLE
FOR THEIR CHILDREN TO WATCH SO I
SEE A LOT OF UNDER THIRTEEN
CHILDREN SHOW BUT PEACHY
THIRTEEN MOVIES --
AND THAT SIR --
AND I THINK THEY'LL TO CERTAIN
EXTENT WILL HAVE IDEAS BE SURE --
PARENTS THE RATING SYSTEM IS THE
EXISTING SYSTEM THAT THE MOTION
PICTURE INDUSTRY USES TO INFORM
PARENTS OF THE PARENTS ARE AWARE
OF WHAT THEIR CHILDREN MIGHT BE
EXPOSED TO BEFORE.
IN A MOVIE BEFORE THEY OF COURSE
STEED MOVIE.
AND THAT THAT'S WHY I THINK THIS
IS A APPROPRIATE AND AS WAS
MENTIONED BY MY WITNESSES AND
WE'RE DOING THIS IS A RESOLUTION
OR NOT DOING THIS IS A STATUTE
BECAUSE WE'RE HOPING THAT WE CAN
WORK WITH THE MOTION PICTURE
INDUSTRY.
RECOGNIZING THAT DEPICTIONS OF
SMOKING OF EVIDENCE IS THERE TO
SHOWS THAT CAN CAUSE A REAL HARM
AND SO WHY APPRECIATE.
ARTISTRY I THINK WE ALSO NEED TO
PEOPLE NEED BE WHERE THE PLATES
OF CONSEQUENCES AND PARENTS NEED
TO KNOW AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE
SAYING THAT WE SHOULD DO THROUGH
THE RATING SYSTEM WE'RE NOT
TRYING TO LIMIT --
DIRECTORS FROM.
WHAT THEY DECIDE TO FINALLY
CHOOSE TO DO IN THE MOVIES?
SO THE JUST AS A FOLLOW UP I WAS
LOOKING IN THE THE TIME
COMMITTEE REPORT AND IT WAS
SAYING MENTIONING THAT BECAUSE I
WAS TRYING TO FIGURE OUT YOU
KNOW IS THIS A NEW.
STANDARD BUT IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN ADULTS SMOKING WAS A
FACTOR IN THE RATING SYSTEM AND
YOUTH SMOKING HAS ALWAYS BEEN
CONSIDERED IN THEIR WAITING.
SO WHY LIKE CONSIDER IT THAT'S
WHY I WAS ASKING TO THEY LISTED.
YOU KNOW AS A PARENT I'M GONNA
LOOK AND SEE IF THERE'S A HAVE
YOU KNOW.
LANGUAGE JUNE YEAH DOESN'T
WHATEVER AT NIGHT I'D THAT
DOESN'T NOT SPECIFICALLY SAY
SMOKING AND THE RATINGS SYSTEM.
VERBS I'D TURN TERMS OF FELT THE
SUBTEXT ABOUT LIKE SEXUAL
CONTACTS ARE AT THE ROOT THERE
ISN'T TO THIS FARCE I'VE AWARE
OF THEIRS IN A CATEGORY. FOR FOR
SMOKING FINE BECAUSE I THINK TO
THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN'S POINT TO IT
WHICH CAME UP I DIDN'T EVEN
THINK OF IT TILL JUST NOW IS
THAT.
ONCE IT MOVES TO IN OUR THEN
THERE'S A WHOLE GROUP OF KIDS
NOW THAT WON'T BE A OF YOUNG
PEOPLE.
FROM THAT PJ.
THIRTEEN TO NOW TO OUR THAT
WON'T BE ABLE TO GO SO THAT'S
YOU KNOW TO HER POINT OF IT WHAT
PARENTS WOULD SEE IT.
THEY'VE NOW THEY WON'T EVEN BE
ABLE TO GO SO [inaudible]
ANYWAY.
THANK YOU CAN SURVEYS
[inaudible]
ENTER.
I ACTUALLY THINK.
THAT THE MEMBER FROM LA --
DID OF PRETTY FANTASTIC JOB BY
AND WAS MUCH MORE ARTICULATE
THAN THAN I WILL BE ON THIS --
BUT I DO BELIEVE DOCTOR PAN THAT
YOU'RE --
SENATOR PAN --
S. R. ARE GOOD WITH WITH HIS
BILL I JUST HAVE.
YES THE ABSTRACT FOR ME IT'S THE
PHILOSOPHICAL I'M I'M NOT SURE
THAT IT THAT IT'S THE PLACE OF
THE LEGISLATURE TO TO START TO
GET INTO THESE SPEECH ISSUES.
AND I DO THINK OUR FILMS EVEN
THOUGH I DON'T.
IF I HAD CHILDREN I WOULD WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY WEREN'T --
THAT IT WASN'T COOL TO TO SMOKE
SO I UNDERSTAND THAT BECAUSE IT
ISN'T COOL A TO SMOKE THERE ARE
LIFE LONG --
THERE THERE'S DAMAGE THAT CAN
OCCUR IN THEIR HEALTH --
AND TO THE COMMUNITIES HELP
BECAUSE OF THAT'S WHY UNDERSTAND
THAT YOUR INTENTIONS ARE RIGHT I
JUST HAD --
PROBLEMS --
WITH --
TELLING THE MOTION PICTURE
INDUSTRY --
AND AND AND AND THEN PUTTING
SOMETHING IN THEIR DECISION
MAKING OF WHETHER --
THEY WANT TO FILL THE ARTISTIC
EXPRESSION OR NOT BASED UPON ON
THAT AND I UNDERSTAND THIS ISN'T
THIS ISN'T BINDING AS WELL IT'S
JUST ENCOURAGING THEM --
BUT FOR THOSE REASONS I'M ALL OF
THE OF STANDING AS WELL.
IT'S REYES BUSINESS AREA.
THANK YOU MISTER UP.
MY COLLEAGUE FROM LA HAS ALREADY
SPOKEN WELL ON IT SO I'M JUST I
JUST WANTED TO LET YOU KNOW IN
ADVANCE OF THE VOTE THAT I'D BE
UPSTANDING.
THINK PART OF IT ALSO IS THAT --
IF YOU WANT TO UTILIZE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EDUCATE BECAUSE
MOVIE MAKING IS ALSO CAPTURING
AND CHRONICLING CERTAIN ERA --
SO FOR THAT REASON IBM.
I WILL BE HERE ABSTAINING THANK
YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEN KNOWN WILL BRING IT BACK TO
DUCK DUCK SENT IT SENATOR PATH.
OF A CUTE.
CLOTHES THANK YOU WELL.
THAT IS A PHYSICIAN I KNOW THAT
SMOKING IS A OBVIOUSLY IS
VARIOUS.
IT IS A SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC AT
ONE OF OUR MOST SERIOUS PUBLIC
HEALTH ISSUES UMP THE REACHED
THAT THE DATA IS AND WHAT WE
WANT IS IS THAT WE WANT.
TO AND ASK THAT THE MOTION
PICTURE INDUSTRY BE ENGAGED.
AND TRYING TO LIMIT EXPOSURE TO
DEPICTIONS OF SMOKING BECAUSE WE
KNOW IT CAN CAUSE ACTUAL HARM --
SO -- I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
PARENTS ACTUALLY NO I MEAN THIS
IS NOT ABOUT LIMITING ARTISTS
EXPRESSION THIS IS ABOUT FUTURE
PARENTS KNOW MANY OF US ARE
PARENTS HERE.
AND THAT WE SEND A CHILD. TO A
MOVIE AND WE SEE RATING SYSTEM
WE OFTEN USE THE RATING SYSTEM
IS A WAY TO HELP US JUDGE
WHETHER OF MOVIES APPROPRIATE
NOT FOR CHILDREN.
OF WE AND SO I THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE FOR US --
TO ENCOURAGE THE MOTION PICTURE
INDUSTRY TO SHOW WE PROTECT
CHILDREN FROM HARM THAT OF
PARENTS ARE AWARE AND ARE GIVEN
THAT KIND OF INFORMATION THAT
ASPECT WE ASK WHEN I BUT I THINK.
IT'S VERY MUCH SENATOR PAN AYE I
ACTUALLY I THINK DO AGREE WITH
YOU -- THE
BILL DOES ENJOY OR THE THE
RESOLUTION DOESN'T ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION I DO RESPECT IN
AND APPRECIATE THAT THAT THE
CONVERSATION FROM FROM OUR
COLLEAGUES ON THIS AND THIS IS A
THIS IS A THIS IS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT A LITTLE MORE
CHALLENGE.
BUT BUT THE INPUT THE THE
CHALLENGES WE FACE FROM SMOKING
THE REAL LIFE.
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE AS A
SOCIETY IN THE INDIVIDUALS I
THINK ARE ARE UNMISTAKABLE AND
IN THE IN THE SPIRIT OF TRYING
TO DIMINISH THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
ACTUALLY SMOKE I APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO SO --
WITH THAT --
DEMOTION WE HAVE A MOTION.
AND WE HAVE A SECOND THAT WE
HAVE A MOTION THEN BY MR THURMAN
A SECOND BY MISTER SANTIAGO --
THE MOTION IS --
THAT IT BE ADOPTED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WOULD I
WOULD I MAYES.
MAYES NOT VOTING AGAR CURRY.
AND YOUR CAREER NOT VOTING
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO BONTA.
BONTA AYE BURKE.
BURKE NOT VOTING CARILLO.
CARILLO NOT VOTING FLORA.
FLORIDA VOTING AMONG.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN NOT VOTING.
RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN I WALDRON.
WALDRON OF VOTING [inaudible]
SO.
AND THAT HAS SEVEN VOTES BELIEF
THAT.
I AM OPEN AT THIS POINT OKAY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
CAN.
PREVIOUS BILL WE HAVE --
ME NOW OF A QUORUM OF MISTER
CUNNINGHAM SPILL TO HEAR A
MOTION. FIVE A MOTION BY MISTER
BONTA SECOND BY MISTER HIS AREA
AND MET A MOTION IS TO HOUSE.
NO TO CONCUR IN SENATE AMEND SO.
BETTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WENT I WOULD AYE MAYES.
MAYES AYE AGAR CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I BONTA BONTA AYE BURKE.
BURGER I CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA.
FLORA AYE LOW MOAN.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE RODRIGUEZ AYE
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE THURMOND.
BERMAN AYE WALDRON [inaudible]
THEN I TEAM THERE.
AS FIFTEEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT
THINKING VERY MUCH SO I THINK.
THERE.
ARE NO ABSENT MEMBERS EVERYONE
HAS VOTED ON THE RESOLUTION --
S. POINT.
WAS THERE ANY ANYONE.
COULD I CHANGED [inaudible]
YES.
OKAY IT ESTO WE STILL REQUIRE
ALEJO'S RAIMES TOOK RIGHT NOW
IT'S GOD KEPT.
BIGELOW NOTES AND NOT VOTING.
SEVERAL SENSE OF SEVEN TWO ONE
BUT WE GOT A HOLD THAT OPEN FOR
JUST A COUPLE MINUTES.
EXCUSE ME
.
SEVEN ZERO YEAH I THINK WE ARE
[inaudible]
THANK [inaudible]
THE GOVERNMENT.
OR YOU HAVE
.
WE GOT TO MY I LIKE THE WAY WE
WANTED.
YOU WOULD PICK UP.
LET ME GET [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
MS SAGER.
I'M SORRY. TO SAY WHERE I'M AT
RIGHT NOW.
OKAY -- THAT.
BEING THE CASE THE VOTE THIS
SEVEN ZERO AND THE MOTION FAILS.
CAN DOES RECONSIDERATION WHICH I
TO KNOWS WE CAN WE DON'T MISS IT
OKAY THANK YOU [inaudible]
SENATOR.
BUT THAT THE MEETING IS
ADJOURNED A THANK YOU.
WHERE?
OVER